au lendemain de noël les résidents déry
en pennsylvanie ont fait bon usage de
leurs pelles et de leurs souffleuse
la municipalité a décrété l'état
d'urgence mardi après qu'une gigantesque
tempête et laissé 150 cm de neige en
deux jours du jamais vu j'ai passé plus
d'une heure à déneiger l'extrémité de
mon entrée de garage la neige était plus
haute que ma souffleuse
je ne peux qu'en rire explique cette
femme qui a passé la journée à déneiger
son véhicule d'abord des monstres a été
causée par l'effet de lacq un phénomène
météorologique qui se produit lorsque
des masses d'air froid ballet des eaux
plus chaudes qui ne sont pas recouvertes
de glace
la friction rend l'air froid plus humide
cela fait monter la vapeur d'eau qui
gèle et se change alors en neige en
ontario s'entraîner comme aujourd'hui
parlent entre les secteurs au sud est du
lac d'uri du lac huron de la baie
georgienne lors des vagues d'est ça peut
être toronto et hamilton burlington qui
pourra toucher si l'effet de la cne pas
nouveau il est de plus en plus fréquents
plus la planète se réchauffe plus la
formation de glace est difficile et dur
aussi moins longtemps
le réchauffement de la planète avec un
des changements climatiques
la hausse du niveau des océans plus
abondante et l'effet de la qui sont
aussi des symptômes
en fait depuis les 20 dernières années
la couverture de glace des grands lacs
est inférieure à la moyenne historique
oyonnax au cours de la prochaine
décennie on va voir cette neige se
changer en pluie et on aura les
inondations c'est pourquoi ajoute t elle
il faut agir maintenant pour contrer les
changements climatiques
entre temps les pennsylvaniens devrait
pouvoir souffler un peu
on prévoit à moins de 10 cm de plus dans
la région d'ici dimanche
ici natacha mcdonald's dupuis radio
canada toronto